please join me in giving Patrick Wilson
a warm welcome back to Carnegie Mellon
Thank You president Cohen good morning
distinguished faculty honorary degree
recipients fellow alumni good morning
parents grandparents other family
members and people under the trees who
didn't get here early enough look who's
laughing now you're in the shade
despite the wonderful introduction
given to me by president Cohen full of
those accolades I stand before you
sheepishly a semi famous actor who is
usually recognized not by name but by
hey where are you in a movie just a
husband and a father and I can't believe
this esteemed University and its Board
of Trustees asked me to be your keynote
speaker me when four years at CMU took
one semester of history and one semester
of computer skills workshop and the only
reason I passed that was because my best
friend's roommate was the teacher rest
of the time I was belting out show tunes
and Margaret Morrison and barely
ventured past those halls it's actually
the second time I'm standing in this
stadium the first time was cutting
through to the parking lot from
Highlander nevertheless here I stand
I am honored I'm humbled I'm scared as
hell to be here honored because there is
no other school in the country like
Carnegie Mellon University
no other school that is continually and
profoundly changing the world with its
breakthroughs in science technology and
art humbled because I am in the midst of
masters and engineering architecture
mathematics literature computer analysis
fine arts bagpiping buggy building
scared as hell because I am used to
learning my lines not writing them and I
want to say something to you today that
will make an impact on your lives I want
to give you more eloquent advice then
don't sweat the petty stuff and don't
pet the sweaty stuff I want to make you
laugh thank you I want to inspire I want
to entertain I want to keep you awake
basically what I do for a living except
today it is way more important most of
all I want you to remember something
about today because let's be honest show
a hands those of you post graduates who
remembers your commencement ceremony be
honest post graduates people cheese how
many of you remember who your
commencement speaker was well how smart
ones down here figures I don't I have no
idea it's not a reflection on his speech
I assure you I do remember when they
called my name
Patricia Joseph sorry Patrick Joseph
Wilson hundreds of names read aloud
names like Tana Winchell Walden and
Srinivas in Chandrasekaran they screw up
Patrick Wilson
I mean that's hard to do but that's what
I remember
so what moment graduates will you
remember today for years to come
maybe it already happened maybe it was
breakfast with your family at Eaton Park
just lining up in cap and gown sweating
in the heat
maybe the moment will happen later when
you finally finally hold your diploma or
maybe there will be no moment maybe when
you look back on today it will just be a
blur maybe a wish you had stopped and
looked around let some of this sink in
looking at you now I immediately go back
17 years to May
I have no idea 1995 I don't remember the
date my wife remembers her graduation
date that's because she had it tattooed
on her ankle
I do remember taking a lot of pictures
with my family my friends my best
friends my best friends who back then
are still my best friends today you guys
have made lifelong friends here you have
together you have learned in the
hallowed halls of Porter and or Baker
you've laughed on the cut you've cried
and Wien you've lain in Hammer slag
sometimes all in one night
that you will remember I came to
Carnegie Mellon for a couple reasons one
it was and is the best acting school in
the country in case you're wondering
where the Dramat Saar sitting - I got in
at 3:00 I wanted a real college
experience a grassy lawn where students
throw the frisbee a football team to
root for
am I missing something well I never
threw a frisbee never went to a football
game only thing I remember is that I
know I'm sorry the only thing I remember
is the mascot can we talk about our
Scottie dog for a second listen listen I
understand Scotty's our diehards they
are they are fiercely loyal they are
they are feisty they are also prone to
bleeding disorders at about 20 times
more likely to get bladder cancer than
other breeds go Tartans maybe that fact
about the Scottie dog is the one thing
you'll remember from this entire speech
it's probably true maybe that is the
moment that resonates because we don't
know why the things that stay with us
stay with us memory is a funny thing I
mean all too often you you forget the
things you should remember and remember
things that you should have forgotten
and a sea of milestones huge
life-altering events sometimes it's the
random details the small moments that
just pass in a flash that for some
reason stick with you forever when my
first son was born I remember the nurses
handed him to me and told me to wait
outside while they tended to my wife I
held him in my arms like I knew what I
was doing walked down the hallway sat in
a chair I looked down at him my boy he
exhaled slowly opened his eyes to the
world for the first time and I saw him
take in everything he was 12 minutes old
and his world was six inches clear but
that world was me staring down at him
I remember the Blue Jay crew shirt I
wore that day that shirt instantly
became a symbol of fatherhood to me my
very own dad costume I didn't wear it
again
until three years later when my second
son was born I'm 38 years old
and this is what I remember when I think
about my life
Beulah Schakowsky and Carl shokalskiy my
elderly neighbors when I was about four
Carl smoked pall malls unfiltered and
one day Beulah or bootie as I called her
took the tobacco out of one of the
cigarettes put behind my ear to sue the
bee sting that I had I remember my first
job I was five it was to carry a
two-liter glass bottle of coke across
the street to Ashlee riders house I got
halfway and dropped it I was five and
for the first time I felt the crush of
failure when I was eight my house was
robbed I remember coming home and seeing
a trashcan lid on the floor no doubt
used by the burglars to defend
themselves from Gretchen my German
Shepherd my red velcro wallet was
sitting in the middle of the room my
savings my three dollars gone was the
first time I realized that bad guys
really do exist
I remember my older brothers of course
they gave me the my first taste of Van
Halen our love of music is something
that binds us to this day I remember my
first kiss first time I had sex they
lasted about the same amount of time
remember the first time a girl broke my
heart I cried I did something I hadn't
done since I was a little boy I ran him
my mommy my best friend in high school
was Matt Strome every day
third period senior year we would leave
school to go to Burger King and make
just the right concoction of coke dr.
pepper sprite and Orange Crush and
listened to they might be giants we were
17 and we were invincible I remember
finding an old VHS tape labeled Camelot
1968 it was a local production of the
musical starring my dad
my dad the TV anchor I watched it and I
was blown away he was awesome and I knew
one day I wanted to be that good I
remember my first week at CMU as I'm
sure many of you do I went to frat
parties the cruise along the Allegheny
River had a talent show
I wrote a terrible song and sang it it's
called wind of dreams and the chorus
went like this sailing away on the wings
of a dream it was terrible in August of
1995 three months after graduation
fellow alum Michael Holick and I packed
our collegiate life into a u-haul and
moved to New York City we were not
allowed in because we didn't have enough
money to pay for the toll I remember
getting a call that my friend Matt
Strome from my high school in Burger
King days had been killed in a car
accident he was 23 kneeled by the bed
didn't know what to do I remember a very
inappropriate lighting cue one night
during the full monty on Broadway and
unfortunately I remember locking eyes
with an eight-year-old girl as it
happened we could imagine four days
after 9/11 I remember walking past my
local firehouse engine 54 the pride of
Midtown
I remember seeing all their booths lined
up on the sidewalk now we'll never
forget how they were covered in white
suit mm - I remember performing at the
Kennedy Center Honors President Bush
made fun of me because I didn't have a
bow tie
glad to see you dressed up he said
I said where are the weapons of mass
destruction
I didn't say that I didn't say that if
Washington is listening remember the
first time I put on my night owl costume
on the set of Watchmen it wasn't painted
yet thank you
wasn't painted yet and I really look
like back man I laughed at myself in the
mirror I looked ridiculous
I loved it I remember sharing a scotch
with Harrison Ford on the set of morning
glory we chatted casually but all I kept
thinking was it's noon
I'm drinking scotch that Indiana Jones
gave me I remember every girlfriend I
had even the ones I should have
forgotten in 1994 I remember meeting a
girl right over there on the steps of
CFA she was a freshman I was a senior
she had a hint of a European accent and
spiky hair she was wearing some type of
flannel shirt we barely spoke a few
years later I remember leaving her a
note at her Stage Door join me and my
buddies for a drink
she never joined I remember about seven
years later her walking into a bar at a
party for recent CMU grads I had heard
she was engaged I asked where her
husband was
she said we broke up and I literally
remember putting my foot in my mouth too
far I went too far
but I do remember her laughing I'll wait
for the helicopter that's what you do on
a movie set you think a soundstage would
be able to knock that out it never does
ten months later I got down on one knee
in the stoop of that freshman's Brooklyn
apartment and asked her to marry me
she looked at me she said no I'm wearing
sweatpants this June we'll be
celebrating our seventh anniversary her
name is Dagmara Dominczyk and i bet
nobody screwed up her name when she
graduated we all have a lifetime of
memories that shape our existence no
matter how young or old we are they all
carry the same weight my life like yours
just a collection of small moments in an
ocean of larger experiences it's the
odds and ends
the bits and pieces that we take away
now this is a sparked at part sparked of
the peach that's right Patrick you are
an actor the part of the speech I would
do that take over if I was working this
is the part of the speech where I should
talk about tomorrow what tomorrow will
bring are you guys ready for tomorrow
but I'm not gonna do that big stuffs
gonna happen whether you like it or not
whether you're ready willing or able but
I want you to concentrate about today
today is not about a job that awaits you
or where you will be going where you
will move how you will struggle or why
you will succeed today is you your
friends your family don't worry about
what will happen concentrate on what is
happening try to do that a lot in life
just be in the moment whether it's
breaking a bottle breaking a heart
getting hired or fired find humility in
the hiring and humor in the firing
they're just moments moments that can
shape you forever and then they are
yours so I just want you to take one now
just focus on what you're feeling right
now are you dying to get out of here or
are you dreading leaving is it joy
boredom are you anxious tired hot
hungover what are you happy
no matter what it is just breathe it in
take it take your moment
tomorrow will happen without your
permission
but today is yours and hopefully you
will remember it thank you
you